voilà alors nous sommes ici à la maison
de la praline c'est le berceau de la
maison tels que mon grand père l'a créée
en 1920 et le magasin n'a pas changé
depuis
benoît dijon et l'infatigable patron des
pralines mazet le troisième de la
famille depuis un siècle
cette petite merveille aguiche les
papilles des gourmets avec l'amant d'un
deuxième spécialité de la maison le
doute m c'est mon grand père a créé
cette recette en 1936 trois cents ans
après des pralines
mais c'est une négative en forme
d'amande qui est passé dans un ami noir
on donne à la pâte une forme d'amande et
alors là après aval enrobées de chocolat
dans une turbine que ça va être un
produit merveilleux une quarantaine de
salariés travaillent à l'atelier d'amis
dont certains depuis plus de 40 ans on
change de produits sans arrêt c'est le
chocolat c'est la nouvelle team c'est du
sucre cuit c
ll du praliné
[Musique]
la recette de l'amande grillée
caramélisées date 2636 on enrobe des
amendes avec du caramel mélangé à de la
gomme arabique et c'est une amende
grille et caraméliser donc on parle de
ces amendes de d'espagne des longues est
un qui sont les allemandes qui sont
calibrés oui bien sûr un petit peu
longue
elles sont pas trop ventru et elle
correspond peut-être est-ce qu'on tombe
a besoin pour faire les pralines les
amandes enrobées sont ensuite séchées en
et use puis pesé alors on est on tape
les boîtes le cap et les bois et avant
qu'on met un couvercle
[Musique]
ma peut pas taper des boîtes mazet
produit aussi d'autres confiseries à
base de noisettes de praslin et de
chocolat mais la praline au caramel
reste la vedette exporté au japon et aux
etats unis
et bien sûr vendus dans la boutique
historique de montargis des produits
d'exception qui ont permis à mazet
d'être labellisé patrimoine vivant
je crois que c'est un peu la légion
d'ailleurs les entreprises entreprises
patrimoine vivant on peut dire que c'est
ça ou le mérite ça dépend de quel point
de vue on se place mais c'est un ordre
c'est une décoration et c'est une
reconnaissance de l'état à l'entreprise
un succès qui va permettre à la boutique
de s'agrandir pour accueillir des
amateurs toujours plus nombreux